Donald Trump is spending his third
straight day in Florida major Garrett is
in Tampa we're trying to hold a rally
last night major good morning good
morning Donald Trump and his advisors
don't believe in the polls certainly not
the bad ones what they do believe in our
large enthusiastic crowds and the ones
they found here in Florida they say are
far better indicator of where this race
is and where it's heading that any
public polling on the horse race but
turning supporters into voters takes
organization and on that score the Trump
campaign is still playing catch-up
Donald Trump entertained a raucous crowd
of thousands in Tampa last night i love
my second all my love florida touting a
select group of national polls showing
him slightly ahead we're leading number
one and again questioning hillary
clinton's fitness for office and the FBI
probe that cleared her of wrongdoing we
have to investigate the investigation
folks our system is rigged she never had
a chance of being convicted Florida
polls show Trump trailing so before he
hit the stage surrogates practically
begged supporters to register volunteer
and vote hey all em signs y'all got they
don't mean nothing if you don't vote we
need these thousands of people to push
harder for the next 14 days we must
double and triple our efforts to make
sure Donald Trump gets elected the
evening rally was Trump's fifth sunshine
state's top of the day part of a frantic
effort to capture 29 crucial electoral
votes I think we're gonna win Florida
big I think we're gonna win Florida pick
at a meeting with Florida farmers Trump
weeded out polls that show he's facing a
big loss to Clinton they call them dark
Falls they are phony polls put out by
phony media Trump's campaign also
debuted a new nightly live streaming web
show on Facebook feeding speculation
about a post-election Trump TV network
win let me just say unequivocally we
will win trumpet other battleground
states through talk radio again
dismissing new accusations of sexual
misconduct what's that he grabbed me on
the arm and she's a porn star
now you know this one that we came out
recently he grabbed me and he grabbed me
on the arm oh I'm sure she's never been
grabbed before and they make it so it is
it's all lies there is no shortage of
self confidence within the Trump
campaign but that confidence may only be
skin deep one example Trump's running
mate Indiana Governor Mike Pence is
being said sent to Utah to campaign now
Republicans haven't lost Utah since
nineteen sixty four in polls there are
tight showing some anxiety within the
Trump campaign about holding on to that
Republican state Charlie thanks major